good morning Hank it's Tuesday current
me is actually on vacation so this video
is being made by five days ago me I hope
that has been a calm and peaceful five
days anyway it's question Tuesday the
day that I answer real questions from
real nerdfighters let's get right to it
can we start with some good news yeah
there's a pretty good chance that no
humans will contract polio this week
which is something we very rarely been
able to say over the last several
thousand years advanced trials of an
Ebola vaccine showed a 100%
effectiveness rate the US economy has
added jobs for 76 consecutive months but
Beyonce's pregnant a new Zelda game is
forthcoming and humans on average are
living longer healthier and more
prosperous lives than they were
yesterday or the day before that or at
any time in human history not as dr.
pepper or cherry diet dr. pepper while
we're on the topic of good news it is
almost impossible to find cherry diet
dr. pepper these days which is great
news because diet dr. pepper on its own
is already perfect what's your opinion
on bears um strongly in favor in favor
net in favor honestly a little overrated
opposed to and in favor what's your
opinion of glitter
sometimes Alice will put glitter on my
face and then like several days later
even after many face washes I'll
discover there's still like one or two
little pieces of glitter and then I
think you know if glitter can do that
billions of bacteria probably can too if
you have a TARDIS and could go anywhere
in space and time where would you go
well the past was worse and I'm not
feeling like totally confident in the
future so I would probably just go to
present-day New Zealand because those
people seem nice why hasn't live news
taken off on YouTube let me answer your
question with a question do we really
need more live news what I need is like
a pause button that like contextualizes
the news for me and tells me what it
means how are you coping with all the
scary stuff in the world I don't know
what you're talking about I have a happy
lobster in a pot of cool water does
anyone else feel like the water is
getting warmer
how excited are you for VidCon Europe
and April very excited not least because
I haven't been back to Amsterdam since
The Fault in Our Stars movie came out
and it will be fun to go to all of my
old haunts any why a book
recommendations yes the hate you give by
Angie Thomas which comes out later this
month
and I truly believe that will be a
classic like even if you don't love
books you are going to love this book I
try not to inundate you with book
recommendations but this is a very
special book what's been your favorite
part of 100 days so far I think my
favorite thing is
that Chris and I are at high-fives like
we've been best friends for a decade
without ever successfully completing a
single high-five favorite song in the
Hamilton mixtape immigrants what's the
secret of life I think maybe
understanding that you deserve to love
and be loved
all-time favourite dystopian novel yeah
I don't know 1984 is definitely a great
dystopian novel but I feel like the one
that we're living in has just amazing
world building what's your favorite
Pokemon Henry says the answer to this
question is mega Mewtwo e^x whatever
that means what's the most important
song you've ever listened to wow that's
a great question because of course like
the most important songs you've ever
listened to are not necessarily the best
one there's been a few occasions in my
life when a song crossed my path that I
actually like needed that gave form or
expression to something deep down inside
me that I couldn't understand or look
directly act the first one was probably
the song I think we're alone now by
1980s teen idol Tiffany but also a new
partner by the palletes brothers love
love love by the mountain goat I've put
together a playlist of songs this
question brought to my mind it's in the
doobly-doo below nerdfighters I'd love
to hear what song to our art in general
you feel like have been important to you
and maybe we can discover cool stuff
from each other alright I think it's
time for me to vacate I will see you on
Friday